其他人：所以说我之前来就是来看也来看一下
Other: So I came here to learn and observe.
其他人：学习一下
Other: Learn a bit.
其他人：特别是大家都是人才
Other: Everyone here is so talented.
其他人：说话也好听
Other: And such good speakers.
其他人：很有意思
Others: Very interesting.
其他人：然后我觉得这个实验好像很
Others: And I think this experiment seems very...
其他人：也很有需要
Others: ...necessary too.
其他人：他也反他也觉得很好
Others: He also thinks it's great.
其他人：然后我就来看一下他们
Others: So I came to check them out.
其他人：到处都是摄像头
Others: There are cameras everywhere.
感觉好像就是我们在录那个其他人：
Others: Feels like we're filming...
其他人：宠物的世界的那种感觉
Others: ...a pet's world or something.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
其他人：就希望大家今天玩的开心热闹一些
Others: I just hope everyone has fun and enjoys today.
Shure:  10个币的来
Shure: 10 coins, come on.
Shure:  小杜我靠你
Shure: Little Du, I trust you.
Shure:  you deserve it
Shure: You deserve it.
Shure:  你快快快姐
Shure: Hurry up, sis.
Shure:  好的下一波
Shure: Okay, next round.
Shure:  从8个币子开始
Shure: Starting with 8 coins.
Shure:  完了市场要崩了
Shure: The market is going to crash.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：疯狂膨胀
Others: Crazy inflation.
其他人：对市场已经开始印钱了
Others: Yeah, the market has started printing money.
其他人：已经开始疯狂印钱了
Others: It's already printing money like crazy.
其他人：疯狂膨胀
Others: Crazy inflation.
其他人：大家好我是来自    的
Others: Hello everyone, I am from the Communication University of China.
其他人：我是可欣的室友
Others: I am Kexin's roommate.
其他人：我是来自    的
Others: I am from the Communication University of China.
其他人：我就是i特别明显的i 人
Others: I am a very obvious "I" person.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：就是在在我高中第一次进宿舍的时候
Others: When I first entered the dorm in high school...
其他人：那个姐姐三个月对我说的第一句话是
Others: The first thing the senior said to me after three months was...
其他人：我一直以为你是一个特别高冷的人
Others: I always thought you were a very aloof person...
其他人：从来不说话的
Others: ...who never speaks.
其他人：后来发现其实并不是这样
Others: Later, I found out that wasn't the case.
其他人：就是在陌生人面前会比较i
Others: I am just shy in front of strangers...
在熟人面前立马变异的人
Others: ...but completely different with friends.
谢谢大家
Others: Thank you, everyone.
Shure:  然后刚刚说的是几个币来着啊
Shure: So, how many coins were we talking about?
Shure:  那我们下一个环节
Shure: Now, for the next segment...
Shure:  啊不是 呸 啊
Shure: ...uh, not... uh...
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  下下一下一个介绍
Shure: Let's move on to the next introduction.
Shure:  5个币字开始
Shure: Starting with 5 coins
Shure:  5
Shure: 5
Shure:  4
Shure: 4
Shure:  3 我记住了
Shure: 3, got it
Shure:  3个啦
Shure: Down to 3
Alice:上 吧上吧
Alice: Go, go ahead
Shure:  上吧上吧
Shure: Go, go ahead
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two left
Shure:  哎不让了不让了
Shure: No more, that's it
Shure:  一个了啊
Shure: Down to one
Shure:  然后后面呢
Shure: And after that
Shure:  就可就没有了
Shure: There's nothing left
Shure:  我们后面的拍品非常的精彩的
Shure: Our next items are really amazing
Shure:  我们提前看过大家的这些
Shure: We previewed them already
Shure:  这些拍品都非非常的非常的棒
Shure: These items are really, really great
Shure:  真的真的没有在自告奋勇来
Shure: Seriously, no one's volunteering to introduce them?
Shure:  来介绍一下的吗
Shure: Anyone want to introduce them?
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay
Shure:  那6个
Shure: Then 6
Shure:  你看这啥 6个
Shure: Look at this, 6
Shure:  不能再多了啊
Shure: No more than that
Shure:  只有6个
Shure: Only 6
Shure:  再给大家最后3秒钟考虑时间
Shure: I'll give you 3 more seconds to think
Shure:  没有
Shure: No?
Shure:  我们这波就直接进行下一个环节了啊
Shure: Then we'll move on to the next segment
Shure:   3 2 1
Shure: 3, 2, 1
Shure:  好的那我们结束introduction环节
Shure: Alright, that concludes the introduction segment
Jake:耶我们花了整整 5分钟
Jake: Yay, we spent exactly 5 minutes
Alice:可以
Alice: Not bad
Shure:  可以 OK
Shure: Okay, okay
Shure:  那我们就进行呃
Shure: So we'll move on to the
Shure:  guest的那个拍卖环节吧
Shure: guest auction segment
Shure:  然后
Shure: Then
Shure:  大家看一眼自己手头的币子都有多少
Shure: Everyone, check how many coins you have
Shure:  现在谁的
Shure: Now, whoever has
Shure:  要不谁的币子少谁先上来拍
Shure: the fewest coins, go first
Shure:  给你先赚点钱嘛
Shure: Let's help you earn some money first
其他人：这是这是一个钥匙扣
Others: This is a keychain
其他人：但它其实里面是那个胶片
Others: But it actually contains film
其他人：黑白卷奇怪
Others: Black and white roll, weird
其他人：图片是我自己去拍的
Others: The pictures were taken by me.
其他人：然后今天带了5个
Others: And today I brought five of them.
其他人：它是基本上都是风景
Others: They are basically all landscapes.
其他人：应该是有四张大海
Others: There should be four of the sea.
其他人：然后有一张是个楼房
Others: And one of a building.
其他人：就是很神奇的是
Others: The amazing thing is
其他人：因为它是黑白卷
Others: because it's black and white film,
其他人：所以正好这么看是看不到的
Others: so you can't see it clearly like this.
其他人：需要用光对
Others: You need to use light.
其他人：哪边是正面
Others: Which side is the front?
其他人：这边是正面
Others: This side is the front.
其他人：需要去用光照一下
Others: You need to use light to see it.
其他人：或许能看到它那个里面的形状
Others: Maybe you can see the shape inside.
其他人：还蛮有意思的
Others: It's quite interesting.
Alice: 老公给我买一个
Alice: Honey, buy me one.
其他人：相当于是你如果把它挂起来的话
Others: It's like if you hang it up,
其他人：是有呃
Others: it feels like
其他人：随身带了一小片属于自己的海的那种
Others: you have a small piece of the sea with you.
其他人：感觉你可以去
Others: You can
其他人：就是通过对着手机的手电
Others: see it by using your phone's flashlight
其他人：或者对着阳光才能看到
Others: or sunlight.
其他人：很有意思
Others: It's really interesting.
其他人：我觉得蛮有意思然后
Others: I think it's quite interesting and
Shure:  肖老师觉得这个每张呢就
Shure: What does Mr. Xiao think about each one?
Shure:  一个起拍先
Shure: Let's start the bidding.
Shure:  OK那就先一个起拍
Shure: OK, let's start the bidding.
Shure:  好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  总共有5个
Shure: We have a total of five.
Shure:  那么第一张
Shure: So, the first one,
Shure:  第一张
Shure: The first one.
Shure:  第一张是哪个
Shure: Which is the first one?
Shure:  是有一块
Shure: It's one with
Shure:  这张是一个有着很多礁石的一个海
Shure: This one is a sea with a lot of rocks.
Shure:  然后起拍假一
Shure: Let's start the bidding.
Shure:  一个 两个
Shure: One, two.
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Two once.
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two twice.
Shure:  好我这边出3个
Shure: Alright, I'll bid three.
Shure:  3个一次
Shure: Three once.
Shure:  三个两次啊
Shure: Three twice.
Shure:  还有没有想要的
Shure: Anything else you want?
Shure:  这个这个
Shure: This one, this one.
Shure:  非非常的beautiful
Shure: It's really beautiful.
Shure:  这个我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you.
Shure:  这是这五个里面比较不错的一个
Shure: This is one of the better ones among the five.
Shure:  三个次那就自产自销一下了
Shure: If there are three, we'll just keep it in-house.
Shure:  好了
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  我我我收下了啊
Shure: I'll take it.
Shure:  怎么回啊
Shure: How to return it?
Shure:  我真想要
Shure: I really want it.
Shure:  啊不一样
Shure: Ah, it's different.
Shure:  给你发三个来
Shure: I'll send you three.
Shure:  好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  那我们下一个
Shure: Now, let's move on to the next one.
Shure:  这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Shure:  哦这是一个栏杆旁边的一个大汉
Shure: Oh, this is a big guy next to a railing.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  也是起拍价一
Shure: Starting bid is one.
Shure:  一个
Shure: One.
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two.
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Two once.
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two twice.
Shure:  三个三个一次
Shure: Three, three once.
Shure:  三个两次
Shure: Three twice.
Shure:  还有更高的吗
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure:  三个三次落锤
Shure: Three, three times, hammer down.
Shure:  成交哈
Shure: Sold.
其他人：坏了已经产生的阶级
Others: The class has already been established. 社会问题
Shure:  还有
Shure: Any more?
Shure:  还有一个啊
Shure: There's one more.
Shure:  第三个
Shure: The third one.
Shure:  第三个是一个 出价两个
Shure: The third one is a bid of two.
Shure:  还有一个是楼
Shure: And there's a building.
Shure:  其他的几个都是啊
Shure: The others are all...
Shure:  哦这是
Shure: Oh, this is...
其他人：这张是青岛的一湃帆船中心拍的
Others: This photo was taken at the Qingdao Sailboat Center.
Shure:  这是一个带有船的海
Shure: This is a sea with a boat.
Shure:  还有后背景是一个
Shure: And the background is a...
Shure:  不要到最后一个
Shure: Don't go to the last one.
Shure:  还有一些楼
Shure: And there are some buildings...
Shure:  起拍价一个两个
Shure: Starting bid, one or two...
Shure:  一个两个
Shure: One or two...
Shure:  两个两个一次
Shure: Two, two, once...
Shure:  两个两次哦
Shure: Two, two, twice...
Shure:  他又三个
Shure: He's got three...
Shure:  哎呦四个
Shure: Oh, four...
Shure:  4个一次
Shure: Four, once...
Shure:  4个两次
Shure: Four, twice...
Shure:  4个3次
Shure: Four, three times...
Shure:  so 成交
Shure: So, sold!
Shure:  啊你干嘛哈
Shure: Ah, what are you doing?
Shure:  然后大家拿到手可以直接用
Shure: Then you can use it right away.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 这个如果大家一会有喜欢也可以拍拍试试
Lucia: If anyone likes this, you can try bidding.
Tasha: 是我的把你喝水了吗
Tasha: Is this mine? Did you drink water?
Shure:  然后下一个
Shure: Next one...
Lucia: 这也是压花
Lucia: This is also embossed.
Tasha: 好好那我的呢
Tasha: Okay, then mine?
Tasha: 不管我这瓶就是我的
Tasha: Doesn't matter, this bottle is mine.
Shure:  要不你拿着给大家展示一下
Shure: How about you hold it and show everyone?
Shure:  呃我拿着来
Shure: Uh, I'll hold it.
Shure:  还是给大家展示一下吧
Shure: Let's just show everyone.
Shure:  这个会看的更
Shure: This will look more...
Lucia: 哎我把手机放哪
Lucia: Hey, where did I put my phone?
Lucia: 在这
Lucia: Here it is.
Shure:  更那什么一点
Shure: More like that.
Shure:  对给大家看一下
Shure: Yeah, show it to everyone.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  这是一个纯的海面
Shure: This is a pure ocean.
Shure:  然后还有啊
Shure: And then, oh...
Shure:  还有这个
Shure: There's also this...
Shure:  这个是一个楼的
Shure: This is a building...
Shure:  还有这两个
Shure: And these two.
Lucia: 为什么你开着手电筒
Lucia: Why is your flashlight on?
Lucia: 可是他却没开
Lucia: But his isn't?
Shure:  对纯景的
Shure: Yeah, pure scenery.
Shure:  那就先先拍一个楼的吧好吧
Shure: Let's start with a building, okay?
Shure:  这个楼的啊对
Shure: This building, yeah.
Shure:  一个大摩
Shure: A big model.
Shure:  呃也不算摩天吧
Shure: Uh, it's not really a skyscraper.
Shure:  就是楼的一个景
Shure: Just a view from the building.
Shure:  起拍价还是一个
Shure: The starting bid is still one.
Shure:  一个
Shure: One.
Shure:  两个
Shure: Two.
Shure:  两个一次
Shure: Two once.
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two twice.
Shure:  那你怎么都要买过来是吗
Shure: So you're going to buy it no matter what, right?
Shure:  3个三个一次
Shure: Three, three once.
Shure:  3个两次
Shure: Three twice.
Shure:  3个三次
Shure: Three, three times.
Shure:  成交
Shure: Sold.
Shure:  还有最后一个
Shure: There's one last one.
Shure:  这个是一个海的啊
Shure: This one's by the sea, yeah.
Shure:  对这个是个海的
Shure: Yes, this one's by the sea.
Shure:  起拍价还是一个
Shure: Starting bid is still one.
Shure:  一个
Shure: One.
Shure:  有人一个
Shure: Someone bid one.
Shure:  两个两个一次
Shure: Two, two once.
Shure:  你就不要不要跟gas抢了好吗三个
Shure: Don't, don't compete with gas, okay? Three.
Tasha: 三个
Tasha: Three.
Shure:  两个两次
Shure: Two twice.
Tasha: 三个
Tasha: Three.
Shure:  三个一次
Shure: Three once.
Shure:  三个三个好
Shure: Three, three, okay.
Shure:  三个一次
Shure: Three once.
Shure:  三个两次
Shure: Three twice.
Shure:  没事咱们咱们可以说着
Shure: It's okay, we can keep talking.
Shure:  四个 四个一次
Shure: Four, four once.
Shure:  四个两次
Shure: Four twice.
Shure:  四个三次
Shure: Four, three times.
Shure:  成交
Shure: Sold.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 太急迫了马上
Lucia: So eager, right away.
Shure:  富婆饿饿饭饭
Shure: Rich lady, hungry, want food.
Shure:  好的然后
Shure: Alright, then.
Shure:  现在谁手上的比较少一点
Shure: Now, who has the least in their hands?
Tasha: 你有什么可拍的
Tasha: What do you have to auction?
Shure:  还有12个你呢
Shure: Still have 12, you?
Tasha: 还有12个
Tasha: Still have 12.
Shure:  6个
Shure: Six.
Shure:  我去自我介绍
Shure: I'm going to introduce myself.
Tasha: 没有用呀
Tasha: It's no use.
Shure:  那黄导你先上来介绍一下你的拍品吧
Shure: Nicous, why don't you come up and introduce your auction item first?
Tasha: 4个
Tasha: Four.
Shure:  是中间这个相机吗
Shure: Is it this camera in the middle?
Shure:  ego币直接起飞
Shure: The ego coin is soaring.
Shure:  来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure:  黄导黄导先上
Shure: Nicous, you go first.
其他人：啊不幸的
Others: Oh, that's unfortunate.
其他人：我今天还真没有什么拍品
Others: I really don't have any auction items today.
Lucia: 我好像没跟他说这个事
Lucia: I think I didn't tell him about this.
其他人：Lucy啊好像完全忘记跟我说过了
Others: Lucia, it seems you totally forgot to tell me.
Alice: 讲个故事
Alice: Tell a story.
Alice: 哎不对这是拍卖会
Alice: Oh wait, this is an auction.
Lucia: 因为我自己也忘了
Lucia: Because I forgot myself.
Lucia: 你不是还有一瓶水吗
Lucia: Don't you still have a bottle of water?
Lucia: 哎好可以
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你不是还有一瓶水吗
Lucia: Don't you still have a bottle of water?
其他人：哦好
Others: Oh, alright.
其他人：非常实用啊
Others: Very practical.
其他人：实用道具
Others: Practical tool.
和市场接尾了现在Jake:
Jake: We're wrapping up the market now.
Jake:哦哈哈哈
Jake: Oh, hahaha.
Shure:  他这有一瓶我们这都没有的饮料
Shure: He has a drink that we don't have here.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：实用的市场化道具
Others: Practical and marketable tool.
Shure:  起拍价一个
Shure: Starting bid is one.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  那个 你后面的是不是
Shure: That one, is it yours?
Shure:  我靠这也是你演的
Shure: Wow, you acted in that too?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 这是我的
Tasha: This is mine.
Shure:  要不这样吧
Shure: How about this?
Shure:  那个给大家一起我们拍一组照片
Shure: Let's all take a group photo.
Tasha: 你确定这瓶喝的是你的吧
Tasha: Are you sure that drink is yours?
Shure:  然后
Shure: And then...
Lucia: 啊这个太擅长
Lucia: Oh, he's really good at this.
Shure:  这个他擅长
Shure: He's good at this.
Shure:  也算是卖了一波亿
Shure: So we kind of made a billion.
Tasha: 卖什么
Tasha: Sold what?
Shure:  怎么怎么拍
Shure: How to shoot.
Shure:  你可以定时下或者是怎么着
Shure: You can set a timer or whatever.
其他人：可以还真可以
Others: Yeah, that works, it really does.
Alice: 哎呦
Alice: Oh no.
Lucia: 有点有点背光
Lucia: It's a bit backlit.
Alice: 我的鞋
Alice: My shoes.
其他人：把椅子调个
Others: Adjust the chair.
其他人：或者都往前一点调
Others: Or move a bit forward.
其他人：嗯得往后退一些
Others: Yeah, move back a bit.
哦那要把椅子调个其他人：
Others: Oh, adjust the chair.
Shure:  来来来老板C位
Shure: Come on, come on, boss in the center.
Lucia: 要不来话大家可能
Lucia: Otherwise, people might...
其他人：把把把椅子调个个吧把椅子转过来
Others: Adjust the chair, turn it around.
其他人：有人坐着有人站着
Others: Some sit, some stand.
其他人：不很像那种家族吗
Others: Doesn't it look like a family?
其他人：我那我们往后面站对
Others: Let's stand back there.
其他人：就还坐到
Others: Just sit down.
其他人：坐的人还坐到
Others: Those sitting, stay seated.
其他人：这对站好一点吧
Others: Stand properly.
之前都谁做的其他人：
Others: Who did it before?
Shure:  纯白的是吗
Shure: Pure white, right?
Jake:盖茨先做完然后就是志愿者
Jake: Gates did it first, then the volunteers.
Jake:盖茨的先往前坐
Jake: Gates, move forward first.
Shure:  纯黑的哦
Shure: Pure black, oh.
Shure:  弄个纯黑的
Shure: Let's make it pure black.
其他人：其实只有第二排能拍的哦
Others: Actually, only the second row can be captured.
Shure:  来吧老板站站站到这位
Shure: Come on, boss, stand here.
其他人: 拍照
Shure:  本来最高
Shure: Originally the tallest.
Shure:  然后就还给自己加磅是吗
Shure: And then you add more weight for yourself, right?
Alice: 坐刘婷
Alice: Sit, Liu Ting.
Alice: 坐
Alice: Sit.
Jake:请坐请坐三位客人请坐
Jake: Please sit, please sit, three guests, please sit.
其他人：请坐前面坐着
Others: Please sit in the front.
其他人：后面有个站中间的那种家族照片
Others: The back has a standing middle, like a family photo.
其他人：像那个什么老板的家族照哈哈哈
Others: Like, what's it called, the boss's family photo, haha.
Shure:  老板老板老板
Shure: Boss, boss, boss.
Shure:  来来来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure:  老板站中间老板站中间
Shure: Boss, stand in the middle, boss, stand in the middle.
Lucia:  你这个相机有自动那个什么吗
Lucia: Does your camera have an auto thingy?
Shure:  但是没有
Shure: But it doesn't.
Tasha: 他有刀
Tasha: He has a knife.
Tasha: 不要不要
Tasha: No, no.
Lucia: 哎现在可以
Lucia: Hey, now it works.
Lucia: 哦不可以
Lucia: Oh, it doesn't.
Lucia: 你是没那啥了
Lucia: You ran out of that thing, huh?
Alice: 我打你吗
Alice: Did I hit you?
Alice:比个心
Alice: Make a heart.
其他人：专业摄影师三角架一直没用上没用上
Others: The professional photographer's tripod hasn't been used, hasn't been used.
Shure:  就等你呢
Shure: We were waiting for you.
Shure:  我们算到了其实是
Shure: Actually, we figured it out.
Alice: 我我我我狗的老老婆呢
Alice: Where's my dog's old wife?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 还可以让他们加进来可以吗
Lucia: Can we let them join in?
Shure:  让他俩他俩也进来
Shure: Let the two of them join in too.
Lucia: 他俩在前面
Lucia: They're in the front.
Shure:  他俩在前面
Shure: They're in the front.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 要不咱俩换一下那个啥
Lucia: Why don't we switch places?
Lucia: 因为
Lucia: Because...
Lucia: 这样可以在
Lucia: This way...
Alice:没事
Alice: It's okay.
其他人：你想过来就来吧
Others: Come over if you want.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你在这边咱们可以这样
Lucia: If you stand here, we can do this.
Alice: 我打不着你了是吧
Alice: I can't hit you now, right?
Lucia: 一对新人一对新狗
Lucia: A pair of newlyweds and a pair of new dogs.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你的狗戴花花
Lucia: Your dog is wearing flowers.
Shure:  上面那个够pro的给卸一下
Shure: Take down the pro one on top.
Lucia: 你的狗才是新娘
Lucia: Your dog is the bride.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice: 感谢你特别邀请
Alice: Thank you for the special invite.
Tasha: 拍卖结束之后干嘛啊
Tasha: What do we do after the auction?
其他人：确实这个看起来比较像新郞
Others: Indeed, this one looks more like the groom.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  然后自己玩去是吗
Shure: So, you're going to play by yourself?
Alice: 祸乱后宫罪不容诛
Alice: Causing chaos in the harem is an unforgivable crime.
Shure:  就就放这页吧
Shure: Let's just leave it on this page.
Shure:  那个放白的那个有点就是照到脸上了
Shure: The white light is shining directly on the face.
Jake:OK行行行
Jake: OK, okay, okay.
Lucia: 咱这甚至还有补光灯呢
Lucia: We even have fill lights here.
Lucia: 不虚
Lucia: Not bad.
Alice: 对不起对不起对不起
Alice: Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Alice: 来吧
Alice: Let's go.
Alice: OK
Alice: OK.
Shure:  来吧我觉得这波才艺
Shure: Come on, I think this performance...
Shure:  123456
Shure: 123456
Shure:  6个吧
Shure: Six, right?
Shure:  行 再来俩吧
Shure: Okay, let's add two more.
Shure:  8个吧发发发
Shure: Eight, let's go.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice: Lucia
Alice: Lucia.
Alice: 真漂亮
Alice: So beautiful.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thank you.
Lucia: 嘿嘿我已经带上了
Lucia: Hehe, I already put it on.
Shure:  大家搬搬下凳子
Shure: Everyone, move your chairs.
Shure:  然后回到原位
Shure: And return to your seats.
Shure:  然后我们继续进行这个拍卖环节
Shure: Then we'll continue with the auction segment.
Tasha: 还有谁
Tasha: Who else?
Shure:  谢斌竹呢谢斌竹呢
Shure: Where's Xie Binzhu? Where's Xie Binzhu?
Shure:  谢斌竹
Shure: Xie Binzhu.
Tasha: 点什么呀
Tasha: What are we choosing?
Shure:  谢斌竹
Shure: Xie Binzhu.
Alice: 干嘛老公动手动脚的
Alice: Why are you being so handsy, hubby?
Alice: 大庭广众
Alice: In public.
Alice: 刘婷你的够花吗
Alice: Liu Ting, do you have enough flowers?
Alice: 要不我给你偷俩
Alice: Should I steal two for you?
Alice: 我去偷俩
Alice: I'll go steal two.
Lucia: 不错不错
Lucia: Not bad, not bad.
Lucia: 预热这个
Lucia: Warm up this.
Lucia: 那个那个灯
Lucia: That light there.
Lucia: 哎踩到几进去了
Lucia: Oh, stepped in a few.
Tasha: 他刚才打压我们的市场价
Tasha: He was just lowering our market price.
Tasha: 为什么我们才两个
Tasha: Why do we only have two?
Tasha: 一个ego币两个
Tasha: One ego coin, two.
Tasha: 就是啊
Tasha: Exactly.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  就是那最大最大那个
Shure: It's the biggest one, the biggest.
Shure:  24的话24的话咱们是几个人10个人
Shure: If it's 24, if it's 24, how many are we? 10 people?
Shure:  那我得坚持10秒吗
Shure: Do I need to hold on for 10 seconds?
Shure:  其实点一个然后再点点别的吧
Shure: Actually, press one and then press something else.
Lucia: 好久
Lucia: So long.
Lucia: 表情都不自然了
Lucia: My expression feels unnatural.
Lucia: 文康后面又给我付了
Lucia: Wenkang paid for me again afterwards.
Shure:  不用了
Shure: No need.
Shure:  我点了点了点了
Shure: I pressed it, pressed it, pressed it.
Shure:  打咩
Shure: Dame.
Alice: Lucia我想跟你合照一张
Alice: Lucia, I want to take a photo with you.
Lucia: 好呀
Lucia: Sure.
Lucia: 只要有福星出现的地方
Lucia: As long as Lucky Star appears.
Lucia: 他就会变成摄影师
Lucia: He'll become the photographer.
Alice: 真好啊
Alice: That's great.
Lucia: sorry sorry sorry my fault
Lucia: Sorry, sorry, sorry, my fault.
Lucia: 要不要把它转一下打到脸上
Lucia: Should we rotate it to light up the face?
Lucia: 我们站这边的话可以调
Lucia: If we stand on this side, it can be adjusted.
Lucia: 其实可以调一下
Lucia: Actually, it can be adjusted.
Lucia: 让他给脸上补点光之类的
Lucia: Let him add some light on the face or something.
Alice: 那我们站这里
Alice: Then we'll stand here.
Alice: 差不多
Alice: Almost.
Lucia: 什么垃圾桶
Lucia: What trash can?
Shure:  我有那么落魄吗
Shure: Am I that down and out?
Lucia: 我眼睛好像得往下滑
Lucia: My glasses seem to be sliding down.
Lucia: 我这个眼镜框稍微有点大
Lucia: My glasses frame is a bit big.
Lucia: 所以汤老师
Lucia: So Mr. Tang...
Lucia: 哎可以
Lucia: Oh, it's okay.
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Alice: 我我我不太会拍哦
Alice: I, I, I'm not good at taking photos.
Alice: 你就说什么
Alice: You just say something.
Lucia: 这这这还是你之前的相机头
Lucia: This is still your old camera lens?
Lucia: 你有升级设备吗
Lucia: Have you upgraded your equipment?
Alice: 这可以打鸟吗
Alice: Can this shoot birds?
Lucia: 哇你怎么带这么奇装备
Lucia: Wow, why are you bringing such strange equipment?
Shure:  来
Shure: Come on.
Alice: 我是点这个就可以
Alice: I just press this, right?
Alice: 是吗
Alice: Really?
Shure:  我们我们
Shure: We, we...
Shure:  order
Shure: Order.
Alice: 这是拍上了吗
Alice: Is this being filmed?
Alice: 是不是有点太近了
Alice: Isn't it a bit too close?
其他人：是的 没事儿呆会儿再说
Others: Yes, it's fine, we'll talk about it later.
Alice: 好谢谢
Alice: Okay, thanks.
Shure:  来吧现在我们下一位拍卖者
Shure: Alright, now let's move on to our next auctioneer.
Shure:   来吧
Shure: Come on.
其他人：OK啊本次拍卖的东西呢
Others: Okay, so for this auction...
其他人：主要是有两个
Others: we have mainly two items.
其他人：呃第一个呢
Others: Uh, the first one...
其他人：湿地和口服的牙线棒
Others: is the wetland and oral floss sticks.
其他人：为什么要选择这个呢
Others: Why did we choose this?
其他人：主要是因为有一句老话
Others: Mainly because there's an old saying...
其他人：叫什么叫
Others: What's it called...
其他人：叫啥啊叫一句老话
Others: What's it called, an old saying...
Alice: 叫啥呀
Alice: What's it called?
其他人：等一下哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Wait a second... hahahahahaha
其他人：呃麦瑟尔
Others: Uh, Mather.
Alice:哈哈哈呃
Alice: Hahaha, uh...
其他人：说的一句是叫雅虎
Others: The saying is "Yahoo."
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
其他人：我们从一个币开始拍
Others: We'll start the bidding at one coin.
其他人：一个OK
Others: One, okay.
其他人：哈哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahaha
其他人：1个币一个币
Others: One coin, one coin.
其他人：还有吗什么
Others: Any more bids?
其他人：招手5个币是吗
Others: Waving, five coins, right?
Alice:哈哈哈招手5个币
Alice: Hahaha, waving, five coins.
其他人：一个币一个币一次
Others: One coin, one coin, once.
其他人：一个币两次
Others: One coin, twice.
Shure:  算了算了
Shure: Forget it, forget it.
其他人：一个币两次
Others: One coin, twice.
Shure:  一个币两次
Shure: One coin, twice.
Shure:  不行
Shure: No.
Shure:  主要
Shure: Mainly...
Alice: 我都没有我跟你讲
Alice: I don't even have it, I'm telling you.
其他人：OK一个币三次恭喜你
Others: Okay, one coin, three times. Congratulations!
其他人：哈哈哈哈内部消化
Others: Hahaha, internal digestion.
哈哈
Others: Haha.
Lucia: 就当是他拍的因为那个小狗没给他钱
Lucia: Just pretend he took the picture because the puppy didn't pay him.
哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahahaha.
Shure:  亲兄弟明算账是吧
Shure: Even between brothers, we should settle accounts, right?
Alice: 在身无分币的年纪遇见了最想要的啥
Alice: At an age when I didn't have a penny, I met the thing I wanted the most.
Alice: 牙线棒是吗哈哈哈
Alice: Dental floss, right? Hahaha.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
其他人：接下来要拍的是一本书叫月亮和6便士
Others: Next, we are going to shoot a book called "The Moon and Sixpence".
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha.
Shure:  盗版书
Shure: A pirated book.
Alice: 你从哪偷的你跟我说说
Alice: Where did you steal it from? Tell me.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha.
其他人：OKOK就是有这么一本书啊
Others: OK, OK, so there is such a book.
Shure:  怎么了
Shure: What's up?
其他人：俗话说的好啊这个书籍是人类进步的 阶梯
Others: As the saying goes, books are the ladder of human progress.
Shure:  你们好一脸懵啊
Shure: You guys look so confused.
其他人：这个应该不是我说的啊
Others: That wasn't me who said that.
Shure:  这是高尔基说的
Shure: That was Gorky who said that.
其他人：那我们我们是
Others: Then we, we are...
其他人：那我们这个第二个拍卖品
Others: Now, our second auction item.
其他人：比起步价
Others: Starting price.
其他人：一个币
Others: One coin.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha.
其他人：一个币一次
Others: One coin, once.
Shure:  这个绝版了这是
Shure: This is a rare item.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha.
其他人：这个是月亮和六便士
Others: This is "The Moon and Sixpence".
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha.
Shure:  我看看这到底是谁写
Shure: Let me see who wrote this.
其他人：可能是译文有问题
Others: Maybe there's a translation issue.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
其他人：一本看起来像盗版的正版书
Others: It's a genuine book that looks pirated.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha.
其他人：满地都是月这抬头看到六便士
Others: The moon is everywhere, but we look up and see sixpence.
Shure:  是那个
Shure: Is that...
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 你冷静一点
Lucia: Calm down.
其他人：啊一个币两次
Others: Ah, one coin, twice.
Shure:  2个币
Shure: 2 coins
其他人：OK两个币一次这么胜券在握书都先拿走了
Others: Okay, two coins at once, so confident, already took the book.
Lucia: 两个币一次
Lucia: Two coins at once
Shure:  没有了
Shure: No more.
其他人：两个币两次
Others: Two coins twice.
Lucia: 两个币两次哦
Lucia: Two coins twice.
Shure:  谢斌竹出3个币
Shure: Xie Binzhu bids 3 coins.
Tasha: 他出3个币嗯
Tasha: He bids 3 coins, hmm.
Shure: 他出3个币
Shure: He bids 3 coins.
其他人：这个错版书错版书3个币两次
Others: This misprinted book, misprinted book, 3 coins twice.
Lucia: 三个币两次
Lucia: Three coins twice.
其他人：3个币三次成交
Others: 3 coins, three times, sold.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha
Alice: 哈银行突然多了3块钱的
Alice: Haha, the bank suddenly has 3 more dollars.
Tasha: 突然负债三个
Tasha: Suddenly in debt by three.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha
其他人：因为什么说它错版
Others: Why do they call it a misprint?
Shure:  因为月亮和六便士啊
Shure: Because of "The Moon and Sixpence."
Shure:  谢斌竹觉得还挺对的哈哈哈
Shure: Xie Binzhu thinks it's pretty accurate, haha.
其他人：月亮与六便士这不翻译问题吗
Others: "The Moon and Sixpence," isn't that a translation issue?
Shure:  来吧来吧 3个币
Shure: Come on, come on, 3 coins.
Shure:  啊他给的是吧
Shure: Ah, he gave it, right?
Shure:  我以为他
Shure: I thought he...
Alice: 别说出来
Alice: Don't say it out loud.
Alice: 你这不偷偷拿6个
Alice: Aren't you secretly taking 6?
Alice: 你给我
Alice: Give it to me.
Shure:  他从世界银行走的我以为
Shure: He took it from the World Bank, I thought...
Lucia: 怒赚六个
Lucia: Made a profit of six.
Shure:  好的
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  那我们下一位
Shure: Then, our next one.
Shure:  没了晚上啊
Shure: No more tonight, huh?
Shure:  还有还有
Shure: There's more, there's more.
Shure:  小杜
Shure: Xiaodu.
其他人：这是我从学校带的钥匙链
Others: This is a keychain I brought from school.
其他人：行政预言钥匙链哦
Others: Administrative prophecy keychain.
其他人：好好往上拍好
Others: Alright, put it up for auction properly.
其他人：这个跟了我这个
Others: This has been with me...
其他人：这个在实验室跟了我半年
Others: This has been with me in the lab for half a year.
其他人：积攒了那个各种我写代码的怨恨
Others: Accumulated all kinds of my coding grievances.
其他人：然后我大佬骂人的那个语气
Others: And then my boss's tone when he scolds people.
其他人：还有把我那个下班回家的开心
Others: Plus the happiness of going home after work.
其他人：还有在学校里的自由
Others: And the freedom at school.
Alice:啊哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha
Shure:  精华
Shure: Essence.
Shure:  一个两个三个四个
Shure: One, two, three, four.
其他人：包包浆
Others: Patina.
其他人：开过光的哈哈哈哈
Others: Blessed, hahaha.
其他人：一个是清华校徽那边有清华大学
Others: One is the Tsinghua University emblem.
其他人：一个是二校门
Others: One is the second gate.
其他人：一个是那个日晷 上的那个
Others: One is the sundial.
其他人：一共三合一我觉得
Others: All three in one, I think.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure:  那么我们现在开始
Shure: So we're starting now.
Shure:  一个币的起拍
Shure: Starting bid is one coin.
其他人：一个
Others: One.
Shure:  一个
Shure: One.
Shure:  L同学出一个
Shure: L bids one.
Shure:  一个币一次
Shure: One coin once.
其他人：两个
Others: Two.
Shure:  LL同学出了两个
Shure: LL bids two.
Shure:  2个币一次
Shure: Two coins once.
Shure:  两个币两次
Shure: Two coins twice.
其他人：怨念这么大的东西才2个币
Others: Such a big thing for only two coins?
其他人：这这店里挺贵的呢
Others: It's quite expensive in the store.
其他人：3个
Others: Three.
Shure:  3个
Shure: Three.
Shure:  3个币一次
Shure: Three coins once.
Shure:  主办有没有想想想想要的
Shure: Does the host want it?
Shure:  3个币的啊
Shure: Three coins?
Alice: 可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
Alice: 给我掏钱吗
Alice: Will you pay for me?
Lucia: 掏过了我的存款
Lucia: I've already spent my savings.
Shure:  3个币一次
Shure: Three coins once.
Shure:  3个币两次
Shure: Three coins twice.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：贷点款
Others: Get a loan.
Alice: 我可以带4个币吗
Alice: Can I bid four coins?
Shure:  我我出4个
Shure: I'll bid four.
Shure:  4个币一次
Shure: 4 coins per time
Shure:  什么4个币两次了
Shure: What, 4 coins for two times?
Alice: 老公给我买
Alice: Honey, buy it for me
Alice: 我我出的四个呀
Alice: I'm the one who paid the 4 coins
Shure:  5个币一次
Shure: 5 coins per time
Alice: 4是我出的呀
Alice: I paid the 4 coins
Alice: 你压我干啥
Alice: Why are you bidding against me
Shure:  5个币两次
Shure: 5 coins for two times
Shure:  5个币三次
Shure: 5 coins for three times
Alice: 我没有
Alice: I don't have it
Alice: 我不都贷款吗
Alice: I took out a loan for it
Shure:  成交
Shure: Deal
其他人：稍等我先给我拿点钱啊
Other: Hold on, let me get some money first
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：我想我要不要哄抬特价
Other: Should I jack up the price?
Tasha: 然后你说大概多长时间做好就行
Tasha: Then just say how long it will take to finish
其他人：没事儿你从我这10个币买走
Other: No worries, buy it from me for 10 coins
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure:  哈哈哈人家就是那学校的
Shure: Hahaha, she's from that school
Shure:  还有还有auction
Shure: There's more, more auctions
Shure:  什么any auction anymore
Shure: Any more auctions anymore
Tasha: 不卖了不卖了
Tasha: No more, no more
Jake:不卖了
Jake: No more
Tasha: 不知道不知道随便吧
Tasha: I don't know, whatever
Shure:  哦哦
Shure: Oh, oh
Shure:  大家可以看到
Shure: Everyone can see
Tasha: 您来您来
Tasha: You do it, you do it
Shure:  我们的大厨上来吧
Shure: Let's welcome our chef
Shure:  来来我们的我们的
Shure: Come on, come on, our
Shure:  甜点甜点king
Shure: Dessert king, dessert king
Shure:  desert king还是desert king来着
Shure: Is it dessert king or desert king
Shure:  desert还是desert desert吧
Shure: Is it dessert or desert, desert, right
这是啊我刚才都其他人：
Other: I was just
其他人：花钱花的太多了
Other: Spent too much money
其他人：要不要考虑那个首先呢
Other: Should we consider that first
其他人：我们先征一下赔款
Other: Let's settle the bill first
其他人：就刚刚吃了先满意
Other: Just ate it, satisfied
其他人：你那个不是你那叫你那个叫试吃
Other: That wasn't yours, it was a sample
其他人：对对对我我是试吃
Other: Yes, yes, it was a sample
其他人：因为我试吃我是拍的
Other: Because I was sampling it
其他人：我是帮我姐拍的
Others: I was helping my sister shoot this.
其他人：所以我刚才试吃一下
Others: So, I just tasted it.
其他人：确保他的是正品
Others: To make sure it's genuine.
其他人：我已经试吃过
Others: I've already tasted it.
其他人：他确认是正品
Others: And confirmed it's genuine.
其他人：然后这个水果就可以不算
Others: So this fruit doesn't count.
其他人：水果就不算了吧
Others: The fruit doesn't count, right?
其他人：啊这个这个吃的
Others: Ah, this, this food.
其他人：刚刚我们可以先按整整个一个币啊
Others: Just now, we can put a whole coin on it first.
其他人：然后交上来
Others: And then submit it.
其他人：先交上来
Others: Submit it first.
其他人：刚刚谁吃
Others: Who ate just now?
其他人：刚刚谁吃了
Others: Who just ate?
Alice: 调监控
Alice: Check the surveillance.
其他人：我们可以先把下面都
Others: We can first get all the rest.
Jake:我们有15台监控
Jake: We have 15 surveillance cameras.
其他人：们先把剩下卖完
Others: Let's sell the rest first.
其他人：我们最后再来找这个人是谁
Others: We'll find out who it was later.
其他人：首先我们可以先卖这个抹茶蛋挞
Others: First, we can sell this matcha tart.
其他人：这个我吃了非常好吃
Others: I tasted it, it's really good.
其他人：这个东西它的价值在于
Others: The value of this is in the matcha powder.
其他人：抹茶粉非常的贵
Others: Matcha powder is very expensive.
其他人：以至于撒抹茶粉
Others: So, sprinkling matcha powder
其他人：和撒皮的方法是不一样的
Others: And the method of sprinkling the crust is different.
其他人：呃
Others: Uh...
其他人：它的味道特点呢在于很像日本的什么
Others: The taste is very similar to some Japanese...
其他人：什么抹茶
Others: Some kind of matcha.
其他人：反正就是非常的好吃
Others: Anyway, it's very delicious.
其他人：那我们起来一算
Others: So, let's calculate it.
其他人：一共只有两个
Others: There are only two of them.
所以
Others: So...
其他人：我们更希望它能成双成对的卖出去
Others: We prefer to sell them in pairs.
其他人：所以我们起拍一介
Others: So, we start the bid with one.
Lucia: 不是不是我想喝口水
Lucia: No, no, I just want a drink of water.
就按一个蛋挞一个币其他人：
Others: Let's price one tart for one coin.
其他人：一个蛋挞一个币
Others: One tart for one coin.
其他人：抹茶抹茶比较贵
Others: Matcha is quite expensive.
其他人：所以我们一个蛋挞一个币
Others: So, one tart for one coin.
Shure:  一个蛋挞一个币
Shure: One tart for one coin.
其他人：一个蛋挞一个币对
Others: One tart for one coin, right.
Shure:  我真好饿呀
Shure: I'm so hungry.
其他人：哈哈哈拍拍拍起拍
Others: Hahaha, snap snap snap.
Shure:  你先给我来一个 我就我就一个币
Shure: Give me one first, just one coin.
其他人： 好一个币有没有啊
Others: Okay, does anyone have one coin?
其他人： 因为我们只有两个抹茶的
Others: Because we only have two matcha ones.
其他人： 剩下这些都比较多
Others: The rest are more.
Shure:  OK成交成交
Shure: OK, deal, deal.
Shure:  来吧给你一个币
Shure: Here, I'll give you one coin.
其他人：然后你拿一个过来
Others: Then you take one.
Shure:  我可以再拿一个吗
Shure: Can I take one more?
其他人：再拿一个另外的价钱
Others: Taking another one has a different price.
其他人：因为他现在已经只剩一个
Others: Because now there's only one left.
其他人：他就他可能要升级一点的
Others: So it might need an upgrade.
其他人：你先拿一个
Others: You take one first.
Shure:  OK我先拿一个
Shure: OK, I'll take one first.
其他人：对我你可以考虑拿第二个
Others: Yes, you can consider taking a second one.
其他人：哪个是比较差的多一点是不是
Others: Which one is a bit worse, right?
Shure:  这个是吗
Shure: Is it this one?
Shure:  这是蛋挞是吧
Shure: This is an egg tart, right?
Shure:  这带盘的的
Shure: This one comes with a plate.
Shure:  带盘的是一会再拍哦
Shure: The one with a plate will be photographed later.
其他人：啊好那我们拍第二个
Others: Ah, okay, then we'll take the second one.
其他人：因为他现在只剩一个
Others: Because now there's only one left.
其他人：所以我们可以附赠一个
Others: So we can include one as a gift.
其他人：你举着抹茶蛋挞拍照的机会
Others: You get a chance to take a photo holding the matcha egg tart.
其他人：可以吧天呐我们现在销售哈哈哈
Others: Okay, my goodness, we're selling now, hahaha.
Lucia: 这怎么打不开了
Lucia: Why won't this open?
其他人：所以所以我们这个呢
Others: So, so for this one,
其他人：所以我们这个
Others: so for this one,
其他人：可以附赠一个举着抹茶蛋挞拍照
Others: we can include a photo holding the matcha egg tart.
其他人：所以呢按理来说它应该价值两个币
Others: So, logically, it should be worth two coins.
其他人：当然还有一个币起牌能不能能不能
Others: Of course, there's one more coin for raising the sign, can it, can it?
你其他人：喂啊OK一个我喂就是例外的价钱
Others: Hey, okay, one for me, which is an exceptional price.
其他人：我也可以喂就是例外的价钱
Others: I can also, which is an exceptional price.
其他人：好一个币还有没有别的了
Others: Okay, one coin, is there anything else?
一个币起开就有人出一个币其他人：
Others: One coin, just someone bid one coin.
其他人：然后我来找骑手
Others: Then I'll find the rider.
其他人：是骑手的责任不是你的责任
Others: It's the rider's responsibility, not yours.
Lucia: 哪个
Lucia: Which one?
其他人：还有吗快
Others: Is there any more? Hurry up.
花丛：没有那只有一个币快
Huacong: No, there's only one coin left. Hurry up.
其他人：那你那你搜他一下之前的那个
Others: Then, search him for the previous one.
其他人：哦官方的配送还是啥啊
Others: Oh, is it the official delivery or what?
其他人：没声那你们那搜搜来
Others: It's silent. You guys search for it.
其他人：上来你可以跟他拍个照啊
Others: Come up, you can take a photo with him.
其他人：我要和他合照
Others: I want a photo with him.
Shure:  要吗
Shure: Do you want it?
其他人：对你可以你可以啊
Others: Yes, you can, you can.
其他人：你卖的是合照券不是商品哦
Others: What you're selling is a photo coupon, not a product.
其他人：商品盒合照券只不过没人出两个字
Others: The product and the photo coupon, it's just two words missing.
其他人：你可以跟他合照一下
Others: You can take a photo with him.
其他人：这个这个和这个架子
Others: This one, and this stand.
其他人：或者你想单独取了他
Others: Or if you want to take him alone.
Lucia: 哎我把我手机扔哪了
Lucia: Hey, where did I throw my phone?
哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
(Hahaha)
其他人：那为什么是你在收钱啊
Others: Then why are you the one collecting money?
其他人：我们是友好的合作我可以给你冠名权可以白送你
Others: We are cooperating friendly. I can give you the naming rights for free.
其他人：哈
Others: Ha.
Tasha: 有种在跟明星甜品合照的感觉
Tasha: Feels like taking a photo with a celebrity dessert.
其他人：哈
Others: Ha.
其他人：我们接下来要拍这个
Others: Next, we need to shoot this.
Shure:  你想吃哪个
Shure: Which one do you want to eat?
其他人：虽然虽然我我就
Others: Even though, even though I...
Jake:和主厨握手的机会
Jake: A chance to shake hands with the chef.
其他人：OK好
Others: OK, alright.
其他人：我就很喜欢吃这个
Others: I just really like eating this.
其他人：所以他就剩了一个
Others: So there's only one left.
其他人：这个里面他的优势在于他有这个
Others: His advantage is that he has this.
Lucia: 怎么是所以啊
Lucia: Why is it "so"?
其他人：还有这个巧克力豆
Others: And these chocolate chips.
其他人：比草莓就味道就不一样
Others: It's different from the taste of strawberries.
其他人：非常适合这个巧克力粉的设计理念
Others: Perfectly fits the design concept of chocolate powder.
其他人：呃因为考虑到他也是孤品呢
Others: Uh, considering it's also a unique item.
就可以和主厨握一下手其他人：
Others: You can shake hands with the chef.
其他人：这个握手的价钱呢另算
Others: The price for shaking hands is extra.
其他人：呃但是呢
Others: Uh, but...
其他人：
Others:
其他人：我们就附赠合照的机会对吧
Others: We'll include a group photo opportunity, right?
其他人：所以所以起拍价是一个币
Others: So the starting bid is one coin.
其他人：然后握手呢
Others: And a handshake?
其他人：握一个币
Others: One coin for a handshake.
其他人：好哈哈哈
Others: Okay, haha.
其他人：我们当然我们也可以单独拍摄
Others: Of course, we can also take individual photos.
其他人：我们也可以先不握手
Others: We can skip the handshake for now.
其他人：因为后面握手机会还有很多
Others: There will be plenty of chances for handshakes later.
其他人：好我们起拍价是一个币
Others: Okay, the starting bid is one coin.
其他人：快了不要流拍了
Others: Hurry, we don't want this to be passed.
其他人：不要流拍了吧
Others: Let's not pass this up.
其他人：一个币
Others: One coin.
其他人：一个币真的没有吗
Others: Really, no one for one coin?
其他人：一个币一次
Others: One coin going once.
Shure:  一个币一次
Shure: One coin going once.
其他人：坏了要流拍了
Others: Oh no, it's going to be passed.
其他人：这个时候
Others: At this moment...
其他人：我们家有一些内幕人员
Others: We have some insiders here.
其他人：出点钱我听见谢云竹
Others: Someone bid, I heard Xie Yunzhu.
Shure:  我出我出我出一个币
Shure: I'll bid, I'll bid one coin.
其他人：那那如果没有的话
Others: Well, if no one else...
其他人：那就那就又又拍给你了
Others: Then it'll go to you again.
其他人：你给我一个币就可以了
Others: Just give me one coin.
其他人：那你那你要和主主握手吗
Others: Do you want to shake hands with the host?
Shure:  我我
Shure: I, I...
Shure:  我一会再握吧
Shure: I'll shake hands later.
其他人：来你一会再握
Others: Alright, you can shake later.
其他人：那就是两个币
Others: That makes it two coins.
其他人：握手来来
Others: Shake hands, come on.
其他人：握个手然后这个都送给他
Others: Shake hands, and this all goes to him.
其他人：握手可以拍照
Others: A handshake includes a photo.
其他人：你还可以选择
Others: You can choose.
Shure:  算了算了算了
Shure: Forget it, forget it.
其他人：那你握握手
Others: Then shake hands.
其他人：好吧那你可以把这个拿走
Others: Alright, you can take this.
Shure:  谢谢谢谢
Shure: Thank you, thank you.
其他人：后面有戏剧相当于
Others: There's a scene coming up, like a drama.
其他人：好呃
Others: Okay, um...
其他人：剩下的我们可以先拍这个麻薯
Others: Next, we can shoot this mochi.
其他人：这个麻薯我们特别可爱
Others: This mochi is super cute.
这其他人：个我们就一个一盒一个粒
Others: We just have one box, one piece each.
哈哈哈其他人：
Others: Haha
其他人：因为这个麻薯属于量制作
Others: Because this mochi is mass-produced.
其他人：蛋挞它属于特别制作
Others: The egg tart is specially made.
其他人：而且蛋挞都是孤品
Others: And each egg tart is unique.
其他人：麻薯它现在还不是孤品
Others: The mochi is not unique yet.
其他人：我们是市场调解的
Others: We're adjusting to the market.
其他人：好吧这个第一个人买的是可以选的
Others: Okay, the first person to buy can choose.
第一个人买可以选
Others: The first buyer can choose.
其他人：这个和这个就后面
Others: This and this, for later.
其他人：比如说如果第一个人选了他
Others: For example, if the first person chooses this,
其他人：后面就只有巧克力了
Others: then only chocolate will be left for others.
其他人：哦好
Others: Oh, okay.
Alice: 那个蛋挞应该这样
Alice: The egg tart should be like this.
Alice: 我的臀部翘的可以顶起一瓶汽水
Alice: My hips are so perky they can hold up a soda bottle.
其他人：来一个币
Others: Here's one token.
其他人：好一个币有没有
Others: Okay, one token, anyone?
其他人：有没有加价的
Others: Any higher offers?
其他人：我给你选口味
Others: I'll let you choose the flavor.
其他人：这个口味是，是是是
其他人：巧克力和啥呀啊
Others: Chocolate and what else?
Tasha: 豆乳
Tasha: Soybean.
其他人：巧克力粉
Others: Chocolate powder.
其他人：哦OK黄豆粉
Others: Oh, okay, soybean powder.
其他人：豆腐豆腐
Others: Tofu, tofu.
Alice: 我快没story了
Alice: I'm running out of story.
Alice:只有5个g了
Alice: Only 5 gigs left.
其他人：两个币可以选口味
Others: Two tokens can choose the flavor.
其他人：这位先生
Others: Sir,
其他人：用两个币争取到选口味的机会
Others: use two tokens to get the chance to choose the flavor.
其他人：还有没有啊嗯好
Others: Anyone else? Okay.
Lucia: 我记得这里放了一包
Lucia: I remember there was a packet here.
其他人：送
Others: Give it away.
其他人：那你可以来选纸
Others: Then you can choose the paper.
其他人：刚才见到一包纸
Others: I saw a packet of paper earlier.
其他人：那是应该有一包
Others: There should be a packet.
Lucia: 那是应该有一包
Lucia: There should be a packet.
Lucia: 可能用完了
Lucia: Maybe it's used up.
其他人：这是一个两个巧克力
Others: This is one, two chocolates.
其他人：你要巧克力
Others: Do you want chocolate?
Alice: 啥玩意
Alice: What?
其他人：好呀那我们现在拍卖还可以选口味
Others: Okay, so now we can choose the flavor in the auction.
其他人：还可以有选口味的机会
Others: You still have the chance to choose the flavor.
其他人：我觉得非常宝贵
Others: I think it's very valuable.
其他人：因为你后面拍的话就买不到
Others: Because if you bid later, you won't be able to get it.
其他人：就没有办法选口味了
Others: You won't be able to choose the flavor.
其他人：那我们依旧是一个币起拍
Others: So, we start the bidding at one coin.
其他人：但是我们历史参考价都是两个币
Others: But our historical reference price is two coins.
其他人：哈哈哈历史参考价是两个币
Others: Haha, the historical reference price is two coins.
其他人：好有没有出价的
Others: Okay, any bids?
其他人：来一个币
Others: One coin.
其他人：一个币好
Others: One coin, alright.
其他人：两个币还有没有了
Others: Two coins, anyone else?
Shure:  就是不让老板吃上饭是吧
Shure: So you're not letting the boss eat, huh?
其他人：哈哈哈还有没有了
Others: Hahaha, anyone else?
其他人：哦好那就两个币
Others: Oh, okay, then it's two coins.
其他人：很明显
Others: It's obvious.
Alice: 录着呢
Alice: It's recording.
Alice: 还有这个
Alice: And this too.
其他人：哈哈哈送你的麻薯
Others: Hahaha, here's your mochi.
其他人：麻薯
Others: Mochi.
其他人：我们可以可以等待时间检验一下
Others: We can wait for time to test it.
其他人：我们现在先拍这个纸杯蛋糕
Others: Now, let's auction this cupcake.
Alice: 怎么回事
Alice: What's going on?
这是一个新品其他人：
Others: This is a new product.
Lucia: 我决定偷走一个谢谢你
Lucia: I decided to steal one, thank you.
其他人：这个纸杯蛋糕它的优势在于
Others: The advantage of this cupcake is that
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you.
其他人：它附赠一个纸杯
Others: It comes with a paper cup.
其他人：哈哈是一个非常环保的纸杯
Others: Haha, it's a very eco-friendly paper cup.
其他人：而且它这上面的草莓的个数比较多
Others: And it has more strawberries on top.
Lucia: 不是我刚咬了一个
Lucia: No, I just took a bite.
Lucia: 你可以问问大家吃不吃
Lucia: You can ask everyone if they want to eat it.
其他人：至少都是有两半草莓
Others: At least there are two halves of strawberries.
我们刚刚卖的这个抹茶蛋挞是半价其他人：
Others: The matcha tart we just sold was half price.
Lucia: 吃吗买下的同学请大家吃
Lucia: Do you want it? The person who bought it can share it with everyone.
其他人：草莓
Others: Strawberries.
其他人：呃同样这个
Others: Uh, the same with this one.
Lucia: 快放这吧一会想吃的时候可以吃
Lucia: Quick, put it here so we can eat it later.
其他人：这个纸杯蛋糕是一个币一个
Others: This cupcake is one coin each.
Lucia: 我蘸一下
Lucia: I'll dip it.
其他人：但是两个币三个
Others: But two coins for three.
其他人：呃所以我们就可以以任意的价格起牌
Others: Uh, so we can start bidding at any price.
Tasha: 啊应该5分钟左右能到
Tasha: Ah, it should arrive in about 5 minutes.
其他人：是一个币买一个还是两个币买三个
Others: Is it one coin for one or two coins for three?
其他人：你们可以选好
Others: You can choose.
Alice: 有人吗
Alice: Anyone here?
Alice: 外卖怎么了吗
Alice: What's up with the delivery?
Alice:外卖怎么了吗刚刚
其他人：说骑手不配送
Others: They said the delivery guy won't deliver.
Alice:为什么
Alice: Why?
其他人：就那个太大了
Others: Because it's too big.
其他人：然后让他们切开多拿几个盒装
Others: They asked them to cut it up and pack it in several boxes.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
反正已经反正已经带了其他人：
Others: Anyway, we've already brought it.
其他人：觉得我们可以走一下
Others: We think we can go ahead.
其他人：迅速销售
Others: Quick sale.
其他人：这东西卖的不能让他连盆直接端走呀
Others: We can't let them take away the whole pot.
Shure:  那大家就那个
Shure: So everyone, let's...
其他人：那那我们可以一会再卖
Others: Then we can sell it later.
其他人：我们可以先中场休息一下
Others: Let's take a break first.
其他人：我们前几个部分
Others: The first few parts...
Lucia: 这个餐是不是已经蹲了很长时间了
Lucia: Has this meal been waiting for a long time?
其他人：是在拍卖穿插当中进行
Others: It's happening during the auction.
Lucia: 等待吃它
Lucia: Waiting to eat it.
没其他人：
Others: No.
Lucia: 怎么老喷掉各种各样的东西
Lucia: Why does it keep spilling all sorts of things?
其他人： 错这个放在本来是第二个环境
Others: That's wrong, this was supposed to be in the second environment.
其他人：确实还没错呢
Others: Actually, no mistake.
其他人：现在已经是最后一个
Others: Now it's the last one.
Lucia: 哎你加了一个那个小眼睛
Lucia: Hey, you added a small eye.
Alice: 下一环是啥呀
Alice: What's the next step?
其他人：tour
Others: Tour.
Shure:  tourtour一下吧
Shure: Let's have a tour.
其他人：我操
Others: Oh crap.
Shure:  参观房间
Shure: Room tour.
Alice: 我我我没把那个梗去掉
Alice: I didn't remove that joke.
Alice: 吃吧 哎呀
Alice: Let's eat. Oh dear.
Alice: 绿色的没事
Alice: The green one is fine.
其他人：我们tour一下
Others: Let's take a tour.
其他人：tour之后我们就打眼镜
Others: After the tour, we'll hit the glasses.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Alice:我得看我那个掉了没
Alice: I need to check if mine fell off.
Jake:哪个屋子是那个绕绕的我
Jake: Which room is the one that loops around?
Jake:那我们下一个Q还是要来介绍一下
Jake: So, do we still need to introduce the next Q?
Jake:不用好嘞
Jake: No need, alright.
其他人：好像也不需要介绍对
Others: Seems like we don't need an introduction.
Lucia: 好像到我这边了是吧
Lucia: Seems like it's my turn, right?
不其他人：足够好看并不需要额外介绍
Others: It's good enough, no extra introduction needed.
Jake:艺术品就不需要谢
Jake: Art doesn't need thanks.
Lucia: 能把这个小小马
Lucia: Can you move this little horse
Lucia: 还是小狗稍微搬一下吗
Lucia: or the little dog a bit?
Lucia: 要不然大家可能不方便过去
Lucia: Otherwise, people might have trouble passing by.
Lucia: 好嘞
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: OK
Lucia: OK.
Lucia: 希望他希望我墙上粘的这些胶没有掉
Lucia: I hope the glue I stuck on the wall hasn't fallen off.
Lucia: 啊没掉
Lucia: Ah, it hasn't fallen off.
Lucia: 大家快看
Lucia: Everyone, look quickly.
Lucia: 否则他一会就掉了
Lucia: Otherwise, it might fall off later.
Lucia: 这是一个地中海风格的房间
Lucia: This is a Mediterranean-style room.
Tasha: 挤不进去了
Tasha: Can't squeeze in.
Shure:  我本来没有那么好奇你
Shure: I wasn't that curious before.
Shure:  你这喊完之后我就想看了确实
Shure: But after you shouted, I really want to see it now.
Alice: 我也要看
Alice: I want to see it too.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 就是它的整体主色调是蓝色和白色
Lucia: The main color scheme is blue and white.
Alice:让我看盾
Alice: Let me see the shield.
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Exactly.
Lucia: 模仿了就是地中海地区
Lucia: It's modeled after the Mediterranean region.
Alice:sorry
Alice: Sorry.
Lucia: 就是可能
Lucia: It might be
Lucia: 主要是希腊那边最常见的建筑风格的
Lucia: mainly the most common architectural style in Greece.
Lucia: 颜色
Lucia: Colors.
Lucia: 对是有一点
Lucia: Yes, a bit.
Lucia: 然后是用了墙贴渔网
Lucia: And then we used wall stickers and fishing nets.
Jake:修硕你还亮吗
Jake: Shure, are you still shining?
Lucia: 然后用欧根纱模仿了一个海浪的形状
Lucia: And then we used organza to mimic the shape of waves.
Jake:有啊
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 对然后就随时都可以看到小鱼晴天
Lucia: Right, so you can always see the little fish on sunny days.
Jake:空调开了鱼还会飞
Jake: If the air conditioner is on, the fish will fly.
Lucia: 哦你说的很有道理
Lucia: Oh, what you said makes sense.
Lucia: 要不然现在开开试试
Lucia: How about we try it now?
Lucia: 不行这个因为我用的是那个
Lucia: No, because I'm using that weak adhesive paper.
Lucia: 就是那种粘性比较弱的纸
Lucia: I'm afraid it will leave marks on the wall.
Lucia: 害怕在墙上留印子嘛
Lucia: So if the wind is too strong, it might fall off.
Lucia: 所以如果风太大可能就会掉
Lucia: But I think your suggestion is really good.
Lucia: 但是我觉得领导这个提议非常不错
Lucia: Next time, yes, yes.
其他人：哦厉害
Others: Oh, impressive.
Lucia: 下次对对对
Lucia: When I get home, I'll change it to strong glue.
Lucia: 回家我就把它改成强力胶
Lucia: Yes, yes, next time.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:你的呢
Alice: What about yours?
Jake:还有我的
Jake: Mine too.
Jake:我的什么
Jake: What about mine?
其他人：他的是cyberpunk
Others: His is cyberpunk.
Jake:我的赛博防线
Jake: My cyber defense line.
Jake:我也来收拾一下
Jake: I'll tidy up too.
Jake:把修硕你的房间也给大家一点
Jake: Shure, give everyone a bit of your room too.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
给Jake:点给点期待好吧
Jake: Give a little expectation, alright?
Shure: 别别别我们来收拾一下
Shure: No, no, no, let's tidy up.
Lucia: 这个屋那么多电脑
Lucia: There are so many computers in this room.
Tasha: 你居然是住的人
Tasha: You actually live here?
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Alice:居然是住了人的
Alice: You actually live here?
Shure: 有没有可能是住两个人的
Shure: Is it possible that two people live here?
其他人：我以为这是个工作间
Others: I thought this was a workspace.
其他人：就是负责导数据的
Others: Just for data processing.
其他人：没想到这居然一半住了一半是生活嘛
Others: Didn't expect it's half living, half working.
Alice: 好那可以看我的了
Alice: Alright, you can see mine now.
Alice: 我的在边边角角
Alice: Mine is in the corners.
Alice: 你们来进吧
Alice: Come in, guys.
Alice: 别太夸张 家人
Alice: Don't exaggerate, family.
Lucia: 哇好好看啊
Lucia: Wow, it's so beautiful.